What we're going to do is,
we're going to talk about segmentation.
I want to motivate this using a toy
problem, a very simple problem, and
then we'll move to slightly
more sophisticated examples.
So here's our toy example problem.
So we have an image on the left, and
you can see that there not that many
gray levels present and in fact there's
a histogram of them on the right.
And on the histogram, you can see that
there's this big collection of black
pixels, another collection of gray
pixels, even a little bit bigger and
what's this thing on the right?
That's this huge collection
of white pixels.
And they're exact.
They're black, gray and
white which leads to thinking that okay
in this image there are three regions.
And I would label them 1 for the black.
2 for the gray and 3 for the white.
So the idea is that we went from
the groups in this histogram
to these segments in the picture.
But of course that's on
this trivial picture.
Here we have that, that clean image.
What if you have a noisier image, right?
So here I've just added
a little bit of noise.
And now our histogram is not just
these straight lines anymore.
But we get these
distributions of intensity.
So the question of how
do we break things up.
And the question is you know,
how do we carve this histogram
into these different groups?
In particular,
we refer to this as clustering.
So there's a fundamental relationship
between segmentation which is carving
an image up and this notion of
clustering which pixels belong together.